[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur lcp l'émission on
parle cuisine on parle politique mais
aussi agriculture alimentation écologie
est avec moi dans cette émission jean
pierre montanay bonjour jean pierre
bonjour brigitte bonjour arnaud
montebourg
vous êtes avocat de profession
aujourd'hui chef d'entreprise vous avez
créé le miel bleu blanc rouge vous êtes
venu avec d'ailleurs et la glace la
mémère peu après avoir quitté avec
fracas le bien nommé ministère du
redressement productif la politique vous
à rattraper très jeune 23 ans vous êtes
déjà adhérent au parti socialiste avait
été deux fois candidat à la primaire de
la gauche mais vous êtes aussi un homme
de terroir président du conseil général
et député de saône et loire pendant
quinze ans ce terroir qui a en partie
inspiré le magnet d'aujourd'hui avec un
plat plus que séculaire ou non désuet
le vol au vent pas très branché mais
incarnation de la cuisine traditionnelle
française et en dessin du fromage le
clac btu ne riez pas brigitte c'est du
patois pour désigner le fromage de
chèvre aller dans les pieds dans le plat
le gouvernement met 100 milliards
d'euros pour relancer l'économie face à
la crise sanitaire vous êtes sceptiques
100 milliards ça compte pas pour du
beurre et dans le dos ou des plats
l'assemblée a voté une dérogation pour
le retour des néonicotinoïdes un tueur
d'abeilles
vous nous direz si vous en faites ou pas
votre miel
allez on passe à table tout de suite
cuisine et mon vide ans
alors grâce à vous nous allons donc
pouvoir avoir le privilège de déguster
des volent au vent un curiosités
culinaires en voie de disparition à la
carte des néo bistrot mais je crois vous
défendez le vol au vent
j'ai fouillé dans votre bios pour
trouver un indice qui pourrait expliquer
ce choix alors c'est le plat préféré
figurez-vous des belges mais vous vous
avez des racines algériennes et normand
donc ça ne colle pas non je pense que
malgré votre accent précieux souvent
raillé le vol au vent ça dit beaucoup
peut-être de votre côté et c'est pas
péjoratif très province c'est un peu ça
monsieur arnaud montebourg a demandé de
choisir que jamais je vous ai dit j'aime
le vau l'eau c'est un plat qui est très
intéressant parce que il a une texture
qui est ambigu double en fait
constituante
oui croustillant et en même temps tandis
tout et qu'il est à la fois goûteux
parce que les ingrédients l on peut
choisir différents vol-au-vent par
exemple que j'ai goûté chez un jeune
chef extraordinaire un vol au vent comme
quoi c'est pas aux disparitions et les
jeunes chefs qui défendent la cuisine
j'allais dire enraciné de tradition mais
renouvelé le vole au vent avec des
moules et des girolles c'était termeer
alors celui là est plus traditionnel jeu
voulues temps superbe alors je vois des
champignons je vois du ris de veau
peut-être noncesse qu'avant il ya
souvent du ris de veau c'est souvent du
rideau blanc de poulet blanc de poulet
et du poulet
c'est aussi pour ça que vous avez choisi
ce plat poulet de bresse j'ai vécu
pendant 15 ans
qu'un élu fédéral en fait députés d'une
région très rurale commune la plus
importante et elle ou en capital de la
bresse bourguignonne
nous avons des concours célèbre de
volaille de bresse et les éleveurs t nos
héros du quotidien c'est à dire en fait
suivait la courbe du moral de cette
région en fonction du moral des éleveurs
de poulets presque est une production
qui correspond à peu près à 1 % de la
production nationale
c'est très peu mais c'est un poulet hors
du commun avec une chair extraordinaire
je crois que c'est 24 semaines de
dévolution à liberté à ne manger que les
les érables et ces insectes du cru et
avec avec un cahier des charges
extrêmement rigoureux qui fait qu un
stick même c'est dur oui oui très
rigoureux qui fait que finalement ça a
mené à la sq on appelle les volailles
fines
c'est à dire le chapon la poularde qui a
fait la réputation de la bresse on va
voir si si c'est à votre goût et si
effectivement il ya du poulet dedans
vois la magnifique 1 le ris de veau nom
magnifique
ah bon mais c'est montebourg pour la
mairie de vaux attendez je vais vous le
dire pour moi
brigitte dit moi je dis pullan on
voulait rouler c'est à votre goût c'est
comme ça que vous voulez mais aussi
puisque vous n'aurez alors je préfère
quand il ya plus deux champignons
oui donc la girolle qui est quand même
qui est sorti fin août début septembre
que maintenant l'humidité revenus donc
il y avait pas de champignons fin août
mais avec l'humidité la girolle est un
champignon
des forêts du massif central
essentiellement et je me suis avec ma
grand mère d'aller chercher les girolles
dans les coins secrets à y inclure
regarde pas comment on y va mais c'était
compliqué d'y aller parce qu'on se
faufilait il y avait des des ruisseaux
il fallait remonter des rochers au
dessin derrière elle avait des endroits
tous les ans elle le cuisine elle vole
au vent cessé de c'est un peu de glace
est une qu il ya il ya un élément
familiale c'est c'est pour ça que j'aime
bien quand il ya beaucoup de champignons
et notamment les girolles qui sont
goûteux surtout quand elles sortent de
là de la cueillette est évidemment le
ris de veau ou le poulet ou si on décide
de mettre des moules comme c'est bon les
moules aussi comme elle faisait la
croustade aussi parce que c'est
compliqué ça souvent ben c'est ch est
tout neuf on peut la faire on l'a fait
ça donne une sorte de l'envelope comme
ça comment dire protectrice et en même
temps qui donne le contraste questions
pointues vous aimez vous préférez le vol
au vent ou la bouchée à la reine bas
d'abord la bouche est conseillé dans la
même famille c'est des cousins cousines
et cousins cousines bon la bouche à la
reine et plus crémeuse c'était de la
béchamel a pas de méchas mène le volvo
oui non mais j'ai jamais compris que
l'on pouvait mettre de la béchamel dans
le volvo annonce rien surtout ses plus
petits oui mais la bouchée à la reine
est tout à fait honorable donc d'accord
relaxez vous savez cuisiner ce plat 1 du
tout non vraiment je suis nul en cuisine
c'est un drame mais c'est comme ça mais
alors vous faites pas le marché non plus
bas et faire les courses n'a rien avoir
à faire la cuisine je préfère tout ce
qui compte peut faire la vaisselle
je peux le faire mais tout un tas de
choses mais la cuisine c'est un drame
donc je préfère laisser d'autres agir
mais je dois vous dire que ça m'empêche
pas d'aller sur le marché de faire les
courses bref voilà la vie quoi c'est
curieux est ce que vous aimez où on sent
vous êtes gourmand gourmet vous parlez
de votre miel vous parlez dévolu aux
îles vous n'aimez pas à mettre la main à
la pâte c'est pas ça c'est qu'à chaque
fois qu'ils essayaient c'était pas
terrible
si j'ai pas je leur ai lutté pas
persévéré voilà je vais pas me suis pas
nous et on n'a pas un petit plat que
vous savez faire quand même
allez je vais pas ajouter le ridicule
assène difficile pour moi consiste à
reconnaît
que je suis nul en cuisine voilà donc
c'est fait alors il ya quand même
quelque chose étrange pourquoi vous êtes
lancés dans l'agroalimentaire finalement
après avoir été ministre
rien de vous rapprocher de la nourriture
c'est un d'abord c'est une passion
personnelle que j'ai pour l'agriculture
c'est à dire en fait la fonction
nourricière de la société a quand même
été abandonnée dans notre pays on a
laissé tomber
tous ces gens qui travaillent dur qui a
eu mal leur vie et donc pour moi qui ai
vécu qui était député une région
agricole j'ai vu j'ai vu finalement un
plan c'est l'équivalent des plans
sociaux de la crj dans l'agriculture en
20 ans et voir des tas de gens
abandonnés parfois faire faillite des
drames humains
guillaume canet joue le rôle d'un
agriculteur dans au nom de la terre
c'est un très beau film qui a été fait
par edouard baer jan qui lui-même et
fils d'agriculteur 45 histoire de son
papa c'est ce drame là qu'on a laissé
faire et qui est le lieu en mai pas que
mes mais c'est le drame de l'abandon de
la fonction nourricière dire qu'on a
considéré qu' il pouvait travailler
gratuitement s'était pas donc combien
d'éleveurs et je rencontre et qui disait
je brûle un billet de 200 euros par
semaine c'est grâce à ma femme que mon
couple tient encore debout
mon exploitation peut encore exploiter
sinon on serait tous au rsa et vous vous
êtes dit je relève le flanc danger bouge
pas 10 à lui dise on peut pas il faut
inventer des nouveaux modèles
économiques et fort de mon expérience de
d'anciens
ministre d'économie j'ai beaucoup
réfléchi sur la question du partage de
la valeur comme on crée la valeur kaki
et le profit est donc l'idée a consisté
on l'a fait avec bleu blanc rouge
consiste à dire le consommateur est prêt
à participer à l'amélioration du revenu
du producteur
si il ya une opération j'allais dire
d'équité c'est une marque équitable
blanc ruche où on partage la valeur et
en contrepartie l'agriculteur sert la
société ce qu'il fait donc c'est très
simple pour quelques dizaines de
centimes
indolore sur le pot de miel nous
achetons nous auprès nos apiculteurs sur
des contrats de moyen terme
pendant plusieurs années donc avec une
stabilité une relation de dialogue qui
est établi une fidélité aussi à leurs
exploitations apicoles
nous construisons une relation qui
permet d'acheter entre alors l'année
dernière à acheter entre 5 et 15% plus
cher que les prix de marché et en
contrepartie tous nos apiculteurs
participe au repeuplement terre qui on
finance la croissance de leur cheptel de
leur nombre de ruches donc c'est une
alors on nage ou donne les chiffres on a
fédéré sous contrat 45 apiculteurs en
france dont deux coopératives
d'agriculteurs
nous avons contribué par nos apiculteurs
bleu blanc rouge a installé 3555 rue et
nous avons acheté plus d'une centaine de
tonnes à ce jour auprès d'eux donc vous
avez nous honorons nous honorons le
travail de l'agriculteur d'ailleurs il
ya le nom de l'apiculteur sur le pot
parce que c'est son travail alors
envahir voilà ce qu'on va parler des
néonicotinoïdes aussi en rang dernières
parties de l'est heureusement on peut on
peut ne pas que parler d des fléaux on
peut aussi parler de la manière dont mes
peut reconstruire l'agriculture donc je
les fais ça dans le grès elle le fait
dans la rep' l'entente des amandiers
dans le moule verra c'est pour arriver
dit arnaud montebourg eux je les fais un
lien sur la glace la glace voilà
pourquoi parce que c'est des nouveaux
modèles gol demi qu'on partage la valeur
actuelle
alors on va voir parce que vous avez
l'air de quand même bien vous y
connaître on passe au quiz
ces couacs oui
voilà alors vous allez être incollable
vous parlez du miel comme si c'était
votre bébé vous êtes monsieur miel de
france alors parmi ces quatre
affirmation à propos du miel laquelle
est selon vous fausse affirmation à vous
pouvez les voir sur l'écran je crois le
miel de sapin d'alsace bénéficie d'une
aop b le miel de narbonne d'eysines le
miel de romarin
c'est le miel de lavande et label rouge
et les ruches de paris font deux fois
plus de miel qu'à la campagne
une de ces quatre affirmations
concernant le miel est fausse laquelle
arnaud montebourg le miel de lavande est
la belle rouge ça c'est faux ça il est
épais d'ailleurs c'est le cas de nos
deux noms miel de lavande alors si alors
bien embêté c'est moi qui ai fait ce
colis ce qui n'est pas la belle rule qui
les appellations
c'est la réponse à le miel de sapin
d'alsace ne bénéficie pas d'une aop à ça
je ne savais pas donc je ne pouvais pas
dire que c'est tout alors autres quizz
l'histoire de la cuisine à travers les
âges est jalonnée d'invention il ya une
innovation qui a révolutionné la cuisine
moderne alors de quoi s'agit-il
à du fil à ouvrir les huîtres b de la
cocotte minute
c'est de la cuisson sous vide et des de
l'induction
alors ce cas oubliez de dire aux gîtes
en 1970 c'est la cocotte-minute la
révolution des années 70 on est en 53
pour la cocotte minute
ah ah oui oui vous me posez en plus une
question c'est que l'invention de 1970 à
révolutionner la cuisine a alors à mon
avis c'est la cuisson sous vide
ouais bien joué
dimanche georges pralus c'est possible
et qui a accusé la basse température
mais les aliments sous vide contrôle
c'est ça et maintenant c'est très
utilisé par les nouveaux chefs en
cuisine beaucoup sous vide parce que ça
permet de faire des basses températures
mais ce qui m'a surpris en constituant
ce quiz c'est que l'induction on pense
que c'est un truc moderne vous savez ces
plaques vitrocéramiques bien la première
plaque à induction et date de 1908
c'est fou alors après ça a été très
améliorée j'en reviens un peu à la
cuisine arnaud montebourg vous avez des
influences et des faits des origines
normandes algérienne alors c'est quoi
votre plat préféré qu'ils pourraient un
peu être la synthèse de de toutes ses
origines la synthèse passé de couscous
ouais on penche plutôt du chrono que des
bavures mes côtés j'ai une mère le plat
préféré de la double nationalité
un grand père est algérien il plas
familial quand on sort c'était le grand
plat c'est le plat quand on fait voilà
les grands événements c'était ça voilà
alors après le lapin à la dijonnaise
c'était aussi une spécialité de mon père
et puis après évidemment on a le gratin
dauphinois elbeuf bourrignon aux vins de
bourgogne là là aussi sa marque donc
finalement vous me demandez de choisir
mais moi je ne choisirai pas commencer
la france et les mélanges et ans de
l'histoire de la géographie française
finalement la cuisine
effectivement on m'a dit que la tête de
veau c'était aussi un veau alors saâd
ichalalène will alors la tête de veau
pendant longtemps j'allais à louhans
moment là les éleveurs manquent quand
ils vont vendre leurs animaux et ils
mangent la tête de aux ciseaux résidents
7 heures un couple en voilà et c'est
vrai qu'ils aiment une tête de hocher
alex allouant que jamais abandonné et
j'ai réussi à en trouver une qui est
compétitive c'est celle de monsieur
ducasse et j'ai mis du temps j'ai mis
vingt ans avant de la trouver à paris
c'est parce qu'ils savent pas faire la
tête de veau lieux et bien du cassis et
la faire ça mais une question j'ai
l'impression quand vous parlez de
nourriture comme ça à l'âme avec
beaucoup de les yeux qui brillent
vous êtes quand même plutôt un peu
ripaille plutôt que d astronomie
vous êtes plutôt bistrot du coin où l'on
mange un truc au bar qu'une table
étoilée à écouter je suis mes racines
comme vous tous nous tous finalement bon
donc moi je j'avais un grand père qui
était boucher charcutier sa cote est mon
goût henry montebourg qui était garçon
boucher puis il a racheté ils étaient
commis il a commencé comme ça et puis il
a racheté la boutique la faire puis il a
développé ses enfants ont pris la suite
mon père n'a pas voulu faire la
boucherie mais mon oncle et ma tante ont
repris donc c'était deux couples qui
reprenait la boucherie montebourg en
face la gare à autun en saône-et-loire
boucherie c'est d'être dans le monde
entier bah c'est à dire qu'en 1952
puisqu'on est dans les souvenirs 1952
j'ai le souvenir qu'il y avait une
publicité que je vais retrouver quand je
suis devenu président du département de
saône et loire il ya des gens qui
soutenait qu'une le doyen de l'assemblée
m'a dit mais j'ai vendu des vaches à ton
grand père avant l'accord et il a sorti
une des publicités 1952 où c'était
puisque à l'époque la boucherie sanzot
attention de la cité la la la la rosette
montebourg puisque mon grand père
faisait la roselle week est excellente
la rosette montebourg le régal de
toujours donc on avait des slogans comme
ça qu'ils ont poursuivi l'histoire
familiale or quand j'étais enfant
c'est vrai j'ai je partais chez mais
dans ma famille paternelle
on faisait les ont commis ces faits le
commis deux étés je me souviens je
devais avoir 10 11 ans où j'ai
accompagné mon oncle a à faire c'est
andouillettes c'est pas la même taille
et on n'est pas loin quand même le
morvan c'est le coin sollicite chirac un
peu chez vous bon vivant pour faire de
la politique il faut aimer manger je
pense pas avoir dit ça masque chirac qui
a quand même comment dire
des antécédents une démonstration
puissante il boit il est très fort ok en
france le déjeuner on le sait occupe une
large part et notamment en politique
alors on va passer tout de suite à la
brève de comptoir alors arnaud honteux
bon vous a demandé de réfléchir un
souvenir que vous pourriez avoir autour
d'un repas en politique est ce qu'il ya
une idée qui voulait relever écoutez
tous les ans eux quand j'étais député de
la bresse tous les ans réunissait à
frangy en bresse
ah oui franges et ont mangé le poulet
voilà elle coulait fallait faire cuire
alors au début on était cinquante dans
les années tout début puis à la fin on
était parfois 2000
donc il fallait faire 800 800 poulets et
puis quand le gaz
il y en a plus quand l'électricité tombe
en panne parce qu'il ya trop de il ya
trop de monde savait plus comment faire
donc on a des souvenirs comme ça frangy
en bresse ou en fait c'étaient des des
fondateurs de la fête avec pierre joxe
qui s'était mis aux fourneaux dont un
thé restaurateurs qui commandait à toute
la troupe et il y avait 40 personnes
pour faire tourner les fourneaux et
donner à manger à 800 convives qui
paient un repas qui plaît bien
ce qui nous permettait d'avoir fallait
quand même leur fournil avec sa
confiance à nos campagnes électorales
avec le poulet de ses pas d'argent sale
wayne a passé de l'argent goûteux oui
c'est de l'argent à hausser à ce que le
poulet boîte c'est une grande
appellation d'origine contrôlée
allez on va parler un peu politique on
passe à la deuxième partie de cette
émission va mettre les pieds dans le
plat
dans les pieds dans le plat vous nous
direz ce que vous pensez du plan de
relance du gouvernement 100 milliards ça
compte pour du beurre et pourtant vous
semblez douter d'une telle somme puisse
être injectés dans l'économie
vous avez d'ailleurs vous même présenter
votre plan de relance vous avancerez vos
pistes pour sortir de la crise et la
crise sanitaire oblige à repenser notre
souveraineté dans plusieurs domaines
économiques alimentaires
quel modèle faut-il adopter arnaud
montebourg comment faire face à la
concurrence des autres pays qui produit
moins cher que nous c'est ça le problème
et pour poursuivre ce repas nous
accueillons de nouvelles convives
nathalie mort et bonjour je vous êtes
journaliste politique au groupe ebra et
stéphane vernet bonjour stéphane vous
êtes chez rédaction deux jours à paris
arnaud montebourg vous avez toujours
défendu le made in france quand vous
étiez ministre et puis maintenant avec
votre nouvelle activité
on est dans une crise sanitaire sans
précédent où le made in france est au
coeur de l'actualité et la
réindustrialisation est ce que
finalement vous avez eu raison trop tôt
bon je ne sais pas parce que d'abord je
pense qu'il ya beaucoup de français qui
ont eu cette conscience ya longtemps
vous avez été un des premiers politique
à la porte et quand même on a essayé de
faire une politique du made in france
mais pour moi c'est d'abord un mouvement
dans la société où le consommateur
votent avec leur carte bleue et et font
attention ils votent pas chinois ils
votent pas allemand il décide de voter
français c'était une prise de conscience
entre le prix qu'on doit accepter et le
modèle qui est derrière c'est à dire est
ce qu'on veut des pme près de chez soi
du travail pour ses enfants des pme dans
les territoires des lois sociales
de bonne qualité des lois
environnementales d'avant-garde voilà en
gros c'est ça et la mondialisation pour
conséquence finalement d'exporter tout
ça c'est à dire on se débarrasse ont
fait travailler des gens sans qu'on le
voit qu'ils sont des esclaves qu'on a
mis en concurrence avec nos usines
bon la conséquence on sait qui a gagné
on a perdu nos usines puis maintenant on
a des lois environnementales plutôt
d'avant-garde en france mais en vérité
comme on veut pas assumer ce qu'est le
système productible on apporte des
produits qui sont plaints de pollution
finalement c'est irréversible comme
mouvement est ce que le monde d'après
puisqu'on parle beaucoup du monde après
il sera radicalement différent du monde
d'avant ou est ce que finalement on est
simplement dans une bulle et on
reviendra finalement au monde d'avant
avec la fait un débat très important que
vous posez là une question à laquelle
personne de réponses prédictives mais
mon analyse c'est on a fait la
mondialisation il ya seulement 20 ans
avant il n'existait pas elle a été faite
par des gouvernements qui ont abaissé
les droits de douane pour permettre les
échanges et mettre en compétition les
modèles économiques et la naissance du
prix mondial ça la mondialisation d'un
prix mondial tout le monde s'aligne donc
ceux qui suivent pas humeur et on
déplace les productions là où c'est le
plus compétitive terre là où il ya moins
de social le moins de d'environnemental
au lot il ya le plus de profits pour les
actionnaires
ça c'est la mondialisation sauvage la
mondialisation assez sarr existait un
vasco de gama il a cherché ces épices à
l'aube à zoug haut de gamme à n'a rien à
voir avec ça mais ce que je voudrais
dire on serre les échanges mondiaux ils
ont toujours existé mais c est quand
elle est sauvage que l'aide mais mais
mais et la mondialisation telle qu'on
l'entend aujourd'hui n'a rien à voir et
vasco de gama les échanges ont toujours
existé là le la circulation des idées
des hommes ont toujours existé avec plus
ou moins d'intensité mais là vous avez
500 millions de containers sur les
bâteaux un bâteau peut transporter
l'équivalent du pib du togo un seul
bateau le plus gros porte containers
donc on est arrivé à des niveaux d'excès
et d'absence de règles donc qu'est-ce
qui est en train de se passer
eh bien les peuples ont décidé de
rétrécir le monde donc vous avez
monsieur johnson
qui a été élu monsieur tron qui a été
élu et qui résistent bien malgré ce
qu'il est en france
retrouvez cet avant de s'attarder de
toute façon nous n'avons pas le choix
nous avons besoin de retrouver les
moyens de notre liberté
c'est pas la souveraineté c'est une
conquête de la révolution française
c'est le fait d'avoir arraché à des gens
qui avaient l'arbitraire les rois pour
leur donner à ce au plus grand nombre
c'est à dire le peuple mais qu'est ce
qu'il ya derrière c'est le fait de
décider ce qu'on veut faire
donc quand vous n'avez plus aux
médicaments vous êtes obligés d'être
rationner en doliprane parce que on a
laissé les majors de la pharmacie
délocaliser quand vous tuer des gens
parce que vous n'avez plus de
respirateurs plus de curare pour les
anesthésies plus de masques pour
protéger les soignants quand vous en est
là c'est que vous avez été imprévoyant
incompétent et que vous avez considéré
qu' on s'en fichait tout ça on a laissé
le pouvoir aux directeurs d'achats des
hôpitaux prends l'exemple le plus fort
mais sur l'alimentation c'est pareil
qu'on importe 65% de nos fruits et
légumes
il ya quand même un scandale quand on
voit où en sont nos paysans dans ce pays
j'aide des pommes
bah écoutez donc c'est donc bien que
toute cette classe dirigeante de gauche
et de droite et ça va de 2 j'allais dire
de monsieur hollande
monsieur chirac à monsieur macron ac
c'est pas du tout à propos politiciens
ma part c'est la classe dirigeante
française qu'à mondialisé le pays nous
sommes le pays le plus ouvert d'union
européenne dans le continent le plus
ouvert du monde c'est pas les
conséquences
arnaud morel sont dramatiques pour notre
liberté elles exporté pas et évidemment
elle importe aussi on est dans une
économie qui est ouverte aussi on peut
pas être complètement repliés sur nous
même si on exportait pas on sera envoyé
ça c'est le marronnier qu'on entend tout
le temps si on est second en question
mais j'ai payé c'est une mauvaise
question puisque tout le monde la porte
n est pas question mais ce qu'on entend
tout le temps ça serait la marronniers
turin pontife s'est aussi mérité
non c'est pas une vérité parce que marc
est d'exporter ce n'est pas terminé
je vais essayer de finir je sais quand
vous êtes contre la mondialisation sans
règles vous êtes pour le repli sur soi
c'est ce qu'on entend donc vous êtes
lepéniste c'est ce que disent les trois
quarts de mon collègue
c'est à peu près ce qu'on entend donc en
fait ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
toul alors qu'il faut faire une analyse
que monsieur védrine avait fait dans un
rapport de 2007 à la demande du
président sarkozy fin rapporte la
mondialisation il avait dit tous les
pays se protège et tous les pays ont une
part d'ouverture par d'ouverture
protéines nous on n'a pas de protection
et on n'a qu'un de l'ouverture donc on
est dans un excès à notre propre ça
c'est cet équilibre là qu'il faut
maintenant je travaillais et rechercher
premier en fait l'idée c'est mettre fin
à une mondialisation prédatrice est ce
que c'est ce à quoi on est en train
d'assister et est-ce qu'on se donne
vraiment les moyens de mettre un terme à
cette prédation dans cette forme là de
mondialisation est ce que par exemple
les moyens qui sont mis par la france et
l'europe dans le plan de relance
ils sont mis au bon endroit et ils
permettront de d'arriver à ce résultat
que vous appelez alors deux questions
est ce qu'on s'en donne les moyens on
peut le faire
tous les pays se protègent d'ailleurs la
taxe carbone c'est fait pour ça ça fait
dix ans qu'on a mal on a fait pas
excuser les sentiments que c'est ce
qu'on est en train de faire maintenant
je ne crois pas pour une raison simple
c'est que l'union européenne est dirigée
par l'allemagne elle même dirigée par
l'industrie automobile allemande et
l'industrie automobile allemande elle
dit moi je veux vendre aux états unis en
chine
elle applique votre principe est donc on
ne ferme rien mais ce n'est pas notre
intérêt l'industrie automobile allemande
et l'europe ne doit pas battre à
l'unisson du des vibrations l'industrie
automobile allemand nous avons d'autres
intérêts à défendre et donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle la question va
devoir être posée avec tous les pays qui
ont subi des dégâts considérables et ils
sont très nombreux dans le continent
européen par rapport aux abus que
représentait deux empires qui commence à
devenir nos oppresseurs peu à peu les
états unis d'amérique qui sont plus nos
alliés vous allez maintenant et la chine
mais est donc cette protection la madame
van der leyen commence à en parler
madame la commissaire européenne à la
concurrence également la question de la
lune démantèlement des gaffes à est une
question qui doit être sur l'agenda
européen
c'est mondial c'est le cas aujourd'hui
selon les américains sont les américains
qui ont ouvert des procédures antitrust
50 procureurs des états contre les
gaffes
mais nous pour l'instant on a fait une
petite taxe qui est rien du tout
d'ailleurs c'est moi qui avait déposé la
plainte quand j'étais au gouvernement
avec mon homologue le vice chancelier
d'allemagne qui des mises l'économie
elle ça aboutit à une amende de quelques
milliards c'est rien du tout le sujet
c'est quand est ce que on a nos gaffard
on les construit on a les experts pour
ça on a les ressources pour ça on a
l'argent pour ça on peut décider de le
faire et donc ça suppose pour ça qu'on
casse le modèle économique des gars ça
et là ça ça suppose des décisions
politiques très très élevé est nous à
l'échelle de la france les deux le 2 ça
va être un sujet à la fois pour états
membres et pour le discours aujourd'hui
c'est quand même de dire l'argent qui
est mis sur la table par l'union
européenne dans le cadre des plans de
relance européens dont 40 milliards pour
la france sera financée non pas sur la
contribution des états mais sur le fait
que l'europe va vraiment axé les gaffes
à en les obligeant à payer leurs impôts
va instaurer des taxes notamment carbone
social à l'entrée les frontières de
l'union européenne contre les produits
qui ne respectent pas nos standards est
ce que pour vous c'est une réalité ça va
dans le bon sens où si on est juste dans
du discours et ça ne se fera pas parce
que c'est ce que vous êtes un peu rire
vous dire ça c'est le discours mais ce
n'est pas dans l'accord n'y croyais pas
et c'est pas dans l'accord n'y a pas
d'accord sur les ressources propres pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de ressources
propres
donc nous on va dire une volonté il va
falloir qu'on trouve 350 milliards
pour l'instant on sait pas comment sont
durs incantations non ça ne s'est pas
dans l'accord ils n'ont pas voulu le
signer donc on n'a pas donc pour
l'instant on aura des plans d'austérité
pour rembourser plan de relance
premièrement parce qu'il va bien falloir
lever des impôts pour financer pour
rembourser cette dette même si elle est
mutuel il n'empêche que c'est une dette
qu'il faudra rembourser
or la seule ressource de l'union
européenne c'est les états membres pour
l'instant pour l'instant est ce que ça
va changer
il faut se battre et ça va être une
bataille furieuse évidemment puisque
vous avez des états qui sont centrifuges
qui veulent pas qu'ils veulent pas jouer
le jeu de l'unité européenne c'est le
cas de la hollande par exemple qui est
la nouvelle angleterre si je vous dis
hein
après le départ des anglais alors sur la
question du plan de relance le plan de
relance j'ai fait un travail tout à fait
intéressant c'était pour ma culture
personnelle mais aussi pour éclairer
finalement un ancien militant écolo mais
les choses à dire aux citoyens
les 296 pages du plan de relance j'ai
fait deux colonnes les dépenses
opérationnelles tout de suite là et les
dépenses plus tard plus tard bon les
dépenses qui sont pour plus tard c'est
celle qui sont sous instruction
administrative enquête publique appel
d'offres appel à manifestation d'intérêt
et toutes les pro stock la bureaucratie
et la technocratie temps qu'ils
contrôlent finalement l' usage l'argent
puis vos conclusions sur les 100
milliards
alors je ne dis pas qu'il ya pas d très
bon programme et très bonnes choses dans
le plan de relance c'est des choses
qu'on attendait depuis très longtemps
mais on n'en verra pas la couleur avant
trois quatre ans bon il reste 40
milliards 60 milliards sont sous
j'allais dire sont encalminés dans la
bureaucratie du pays en revanche il
reste 40 milliards dans les 40 milliards
vous avez 20 milliards qui sont des
baisses d'impôts de production sans
aucun effet de levier c'est-à-dire qu'en
fait moi par exemple chez bleu blanc
rouge nous avons fait 415 mille euros de
chiffre d'affaires la première année
pleine à yves dernière et nous allons
nous payons 2200 euros de d'impôt de
production donc on va nous baisser
l'impôt de production ça c'est très bien
ça me fait une belle jambe sans aucune
contrepartie balle aucune contrepartie
et d'ailleurs les entreprises à qui ça
va bénéficier c'est seulement les 285
les plus grosses
mais à celle là vous pouvez leur
demander des choses vous prenez les 290
moi je suis pour qu'on prenne les 1000
premières boîtes françaises
par taille par chiffre d'affaires qu'on
leur dise maintenant vous relocaliser en
contrepartie on supprime des impôts de
production mais vous fait vrai mais vous
re localiser vos sous traitants vos
achats vos lignes de production vous
même ce que vous faites vous même ce que
vous faites mais même en baissant de 10
milliards 2 x 10 milliards 20 milliards
les impôts de production on aura
toujours des coûts de production qui
sont plus élevés que ceux des pays des
vans croit d'abord je voudrais tempérer
cette analyse anti jalibert anti
française consiste à dire qu'on est nul
j'en ai marre d'entendre ça la france
est génial je vous dire c'est génial et
d'ailleurs c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles tant notre pays aujourd'hui
vous avez
des lignes de production qui s'installe
avec de la robotique la robotique
qu'elle soit shanghai où qu'elles soient
à vesoul
c'est la même voie là et les coûts de
production ne sont pas pires j'irai même
qui a même des avantages l'énergie est
beaucoup moins cher qu'ailleurs
elle est beaucoup moins cher dans
nombreux pays du monde donc nous devons
défendre notre politique donc regarder
l'exemple japonais moi je dis le bon
gouvernement dans les plans de relance
et le gouvernement japonais peu connu
des français mais intéressant qu'est-ce
qui fait mieux que nous les japonais
mais qu'est ce qu'ils font mieux que les
jeux vous dire ils ont fait une chose
ils ont dit voilà nous mettons deux
milliards sur la table et on paye tout
les relocalisations fermetures d'usinés
en chine et retour sur le sol national
japonais et on paye les trois quarts de
l'investissement
ça coûte cher de fermer une usine
rouvrir une passe qu'il faut là pour le
foncier fort et embaucher ça coûte un
bras
excusez moi l'expression et donc il faut
le gouvernement japonais dit moi je paye
les trois quarts pme grands groupes peu
importe quoi il n'ya pas le secteur est
ce que le préfet d'accord à ce que
présente deux régions de la corne d'or
c'est allez-y il ya eu
j'ai regardé sur le site du mythique et
le grand ministère l'économie et
l'industrie japonais qu'elle croque mort
de cabinet de guerre un peu hein
ils ont eu 1674 projet pour 14 milliards
même imaginer qui relocalisent toyota à
valenciennes n'avait pas fait un peu
mais c'est la chine
très concerné chez toyota y seront
france il m'a dit allez cette politique
là c'est bien ce policier de la chine
c'est à dire que la chine japon c'est
juste à côté et ils sont allés chercher
coûts de production je rappelle que
l'usiné toyota est considéré par les 2
valenciennes est considéré par les
japonais comme une des plus rentables du
monde pour toyota
donc ya pas de sujet sur toyota il ya un
sujet sur les pneus sur les pneus et
indique nous alors je vais vous dire
qu'est ce que l'europe a fait pour
empêcher l'arrivée l'invasion des pneus
chinois sur le marché européen
strictement rien qu'est ce qu'a fait
monsieur obama s'était pas trump c'était
déjà obama il a mis des taxes de 80% sur
l'importation de pneus chinois qui font
du dumping
conséquence ils ont gardé leur usine de
pneus nous on a fermé des usines
michelin la ferme il goûte guère fermer
continental ferme et bridgestone
pourquoi parce que
on a laissé les chinois nous vend des
pneus d'ailleurs pas terrible à des prix
défiant toute concurrence qui ont tué
nos usines
donc faut pas s'étonner puisque on
laisse faire qu'on se retrouve dans
cette situation c'est donc là on n'a pas
les dirigeants qui nous faut vous voyez
ce que je veux dire
donc là protectionnistes ckoi et font
des tiers parce que les américains le
font les chinois le fond et essayer
d'aller d'aller prendre des marchés ou
crouch peut importer exporter mondiale
aux gens en chine
c'est ce qui nous manque un des
conditions sanitaires j'ai même attaqué
devant le medef l'ambassadeur de chine
pourquoi parce que eux ils nous export
du miel mélangée à du sucre ont dit rien
on est les naïfs de la mort et sa
fiancée nancy s'est passé on ne dit rien
c'est pas vrai
le miel avec du glucose y en a moins de
deux mois c'est moi monsieur
il n'y a pas d'interdiction c'est ça on
ne dit rien vous vous savez mais le
français quand ils achètent former une
semaine en forêt du coin il en compte
dit rien on laisse faire comme
d'habitude mais moi je ne peux pas
exporter montviel ça c'est très naturel
pourquoi parce que en france paraît-il
il ya une maladie qui toucherait
considérer ses efforts pour sa l'achat
mais ils sont très forts mais nous on
est quoi alors nous si ils sont très
forts on est nul c'est ça qu'il faut
déduire de votre phrase bas vous l'avez
dit arnaud montebourg vous donnons mais
quand même quand même mieux de remy je
n'ai pas dit mais vous le pensez en fête
en fête et et nous rêver bébé j'aurais
dit mois plus tôt les nuls
on est des idiots vous dit qu'on est des
idiots qu'on a mal et dirigeants qu'il
faut que qu'il faudrait faire ci est pas
ça et en même temps vous avez totalement
changé de ligne vous voulez plus
justement vous impliquer dans la vie
politique a une je suis à votre émission
pour répondre à des questions je vous
dise ce que je pense qu'aujourd'hui
c'est à dire ici ou là parce que je
l'avais été aux manettes elle pas venue
pour parler moi je suis venu pour parler
alimentation agriculture nourriture le
rôle de l'ancien ministre l'économie
c'est de dire les choix oui bon alors
dit je vous ai répondu enfin nouveauté
fait je donne mon point de vue parce que
vous avez l'obligeant c est franchement
la délicatesse du me le demander
l'artiste vous en remercie donc je vous
donne mon point de vue brut de
décoffrage suis désolé mais est ce que
vous dites on est on sait pas ce que
vous avez été au ministre ministère
début du redressement productif quand on
est aux manettes finalement on peut pas
faire changer les choses
est-ce que vous avez sentiment là je
pense par exemple à la loi florange
aujourd'hui bridgestone est en train de
fermer alors bon il ya ce seuil de 1000
salariés effectivement qu'il est pas
remplie mais on a l'impression que
ballet taille presque impuissant
excusez-moi florange aurions pu sauver
florange qu'avait fait une proposition
de nationalisation ça ça très bien pu
être possible tout le monde est d'accord
la droite était d'accord la gauche était
d'accord avec deux personnes n'étaient
pas d'accord le premier ministre et
président de la république de l'époque
donc ben voilà en fait on n'a pas les
présidents qu'il vous faut c'est tout qu
il suffirait juste de dire écoutez
excusez moi mais là on va pas cesser
mener par le bout du nez par monsieur
mittal qui je le rappelle a fait une opa
hostile sur arcelor était le leader
brixton on nationalise nos bouts d'choux
n'y a rien à nationaliser on perd nos
pneus il faut mettre des taxes sur les
pneus chinois
c'est ça qu'il faut faire et on
retrouvera nos usines et nos capacités
de production c'est tout réflexion faire
ce que font les américains c'est pas
très compliqué américain c'est pas des
méchants mélenchonistes et c'est
monsieur obama et monsieur trump sont à
peu près d'accord sur la politique
protectionniste claque pour comprendre
juste une dernière chose sur bridgestone
votre exemple japonais il est très
intéressant le japon qui payent pour
relocaliser les usines qui sont partis
en chine mais la problématique aussi de
bridgestone qui ferment en france et que
le groupe a investi dans des usines en
pologne et en hongrie
cette politique là qui consisterait à
dire on est prêt à payer pour
relocaliser des choses en france
est ce que c'est possible au sein de
l'union européenne parce qu'évidemment
quand vos propres concurrents sont à
l'intérieur de l'union le leur alors à
être d'accord peut-être pourrais-je
nuancer votre objection justifié en
disant quand vous avez une pression
mondiale sur les prix quand vous voulez
rester en europe à ce que vous avez vous
il ya les constructeurs automobiles en
europe donc on a besoin de pneus les
faire venir de loin c'est difficile la
gino avec sa faire ça et donc les
constructeurs les équipementiers que
sont les fabricants de pneumatiques
comme zadeh près des usines des
assembleurs bon donc ils cherchent à
cause la pression exercée mondiale sur
les prix et notamment de la
mondialisation asiatiques et chinois
eh bien ils cherchent les zones de
basses pressions sur les coûts dans
l'union européenne
donc ils immigrent plus financé par
l'union européenne après quand est-ce
qu'on arrivera enfin organiser les
choses ont bossé pas un homme
je dirais que la question elle est
d'abord extérieur si on se protège de
l'extérieur vous aurez moins ce type de
girbal ça disparaîtra mais en tout cas
vous n'avez pas d'intérêt à déménager
une usine ça coûte très cher donc si
vous le faites c'est parce que vous
voulez survivre n'ai pas d'autre
solution parce que vous êtes attaqués
par la concurrence déloyale des règles
européennes vos extérieurs vis-à-vis de
l'extérieur européenne c'est le premier
point
alors votre autre question concerne la
façon dont les les relocalisations
peuvent peuvent se faire ça c'est un
outil de la puissance quand vous avez
des grands groupes comme les nôtres qui
sont mondiaux qui doivent tous à la
france vous pouvez leur demander des
choses quand vous n'en avez pas c'est
très difficile pendant plan belgique par
exemple leur dire écoutez voilà moi je
vous baisse des impôts mais en viendront
partie sur la wii mais en contrepartie
et bien vous allez faire vos achats en
france dans les 40 premières entreprises
françaises
il ya seulement 16% de leurs achats qui
sont faits sur la plaque france c'est
très peu vous allez en allemagne c'est
beaucoup plus salée au japon n'en
parlons même pas je vous parle même pas
des chinois
donc si vous voulez on a besoin de
patriotisme économique dit dans dans les
grandes entreprises et donc ça ça
suppose une grosse négociations donc
vous c'est pas très compliqué ça va
faire voyez les marchés publics les
marchés publics les a mêlés à saransk
ses marchés publics
il y a que nous qui offrons aux chinois
la possibilité de faire le grand paris
voulu par l'ema trio tisme quand vous
voyez cet accord nous avait reçus avec
suez et veolia est ce que vous dites
c'est bien on va créer un grand champion
français ou pas vous parler du
démantèlement tu fais là on en a deux
champions donc on en supprime 1 on a
deux concerts % du marché mondial l'un
et l'autre donc on en supprime à mai un
plus un ça fait pas d'eux on met ça fera
certainement un safer qui peut valoir 2
la question c'est que il ya 90 mille
emplois chez suez
on va couper ça en rondelles lancées
pour moi c'est inévitable pour moi c'est
une grave faute et l'état est
responsable parce qu'ils ont laissé
faire ils m'ont même encouragé en l'état
est actionnaire mais on ya de quoi angie
n'est pas minoritaire c'est le premier
actionnaire
oui mais à 22% j'adore du coup il a pas
50 % il peut pas y ait pas décisionnaire
à lui tout seul c'est lui c'est lui qui
a nommé clamadieu conversation c'est lui
qui a nommé clamadieu pour faire ça et
surtout quand l'elysée appelle des
administrateurs pour qui votent en
faisant semblant que l'état a voté
contre
chez moi l'histoire elle le dit c'est
dans tous les journaux donc moi ce que
je sais c'est un journal comme les
autres il vaut bien le vôtre au non
moins bon des enquêtes les ai donc moi
je pourrais dire quand même que pour moi
c'est une affaire extrêmement grave
c'est un démantèlement d'une entreprise
saine veolia n'a pas besoin de ça pour
se développer et surtout on est plus
fort quand on a deux champions mondiaux
que quand on a qu'un donc vous allez
voir les dégâts maintenant sur les
territoires et puis par ailleurs on n'a
pas besoin de monopole monopole ça
pourrait faire monter de près de l'eau
chez les on a surtout besoin
d'investisseurs qui refont tous les
tuyaux de sous-sol compte presque un
siècle
donc il va falloir les refaire et donc
on a besoin d'avoir un peu de
concurrence et des capacités
d'investissement de part et d'autre sera
plus tard merci nathalie murray d'avoir
été avec nous merci stéphane bern elle
le temps presse on va bientôt passer au
dessert il nous sera servi dans quelques
instants passés la troisième partie
maintenant de cette émission et c'est le
dessous des plats
[Musique]
alors nicolas hulot yannick jadot sont
scandalisés même au sein de la
république en marche la provoquer des
tirages à leur tour des néonicotinoïdes
dans les champs de betteraves sucrières
le parlement a en effet voté mardi le
projet de loi autorisant une dérogation
à l'utilisation de ce pesticide dit et
ça vous intéresse tueur d'abeilles
reportage de clément méric et rabih cas
au pays des betteraves dans l'aube
donc voilà j'ai arraché des betteraves
avec de la jaunisse par rapport à des
betteraves qui sont saines
cinq ans arcis sur aube le puceron a
frappé l'exploitation d'alain carré au
printemps il a utilisé les deux
insecticides censé remplacer les
néonicotinoïdes sans résultat est la
conséquence directe basset et tubercules
les racines
y'a pas photo c'est entre 30 à 40 % de
perte de rendement il y a quelques jours
grégory besson moreau a défendu avec
succès dans l'hémicycle le retour des
néonicotinoïdes pour les seuls
producteurs de betteraves
mais le rapporteur du projet de loi
mettant garde cet agriculteur ce projet
doit ce n'est pas un chèque en blanc non
plus on a eu du temps pour arrêter les
néonicotinoïdes peut-être qu'il ya eu un
manque de travail de la part de la fille
est en règle générale la dérogation doit
durer trois ans de quoi offrir un peu
d'oxygène à toute une filière déjà
fragilisé par la fin des quotas
européens
car au delà des champs il y a des usines
comme cette sucrerie distillerie la plus
importante de france elle dépend de la
production de betteraves de la région
pour être
cette pitrerie d'ici les doigts de
couple et 120 jours par an plus tôt
cette année elle va tourner environ 90
on peut tenir là parce que là on a serré
aussi allés tous les niveaux mais c'est
pas tenable plus de deux ans la
coopérative propriétaire de ce site a
déjà fermé deux sucreries l'an dernier
en tout 46 mille emplois sont en jeu en
france mais dans la balance il ya aussi
l'environnement car les néonicotinoïdes
ne tue pas que les pucerons toute la
biodiversité est menacée
un argument que les écologistes de
l'aube ont du mal à faire entendre
il faut dire qu'ici la betterave fait
vivre beaucoup de monde le débat a
l'impression que tout va bien que les
déos nicotine sont son formidable non je
rappelle quand même que 80% des insectes
ont disparu en europe ces dernières
années ces trente dernières années
nous notre inquiétude c'est qu'on dit
grange une nouvelle fois à la loi dans
un an dans deux ans dans trois ans les
néonicotinoïdes également surnommé tueur
d'abeilles ont fait augmenter leur
mortalité de 5 à 20% ces deux dernières
décennies et la production de miel a été
divisé par deux arnaud montebourg est ce
que vous auriez voter vous cette
réintroduction des insecticides ans dans
la betterave sucrière pour sauver la
filière fillon non certainement pas
insecticides ces mêmes néonicotinoïdes
la formule chimique extrêmement
dévastatrice il ya eu il ya une dizaine
d'années une étude de l'inra qui a
installé sur 655 butineuses des abeilles
une puce de micro identification qu'on
appelle les puces rfid
c'est une étude très célèbre dans le
monde et particulièrement dans le monde
apicole qui a observé ce qui se passait
lorsque les abeilles aller butiner sur
des colzas qu'ils étaient protégés par
des néonicotinoïdes salaires en elle ce
qu'on appelle le vol de retour l'étude
s'appelle le vol de retour elle ne
revenait pas et pas de retour serre
qu'elle était désorientée et
elle meurt elle perdre la boussole
interne
wisair qu'elles sont perdus donc on sait
tout ça depuis dix ans donc le
gouvernement à laquelle auquel j'avais
l'honneur d'appartenir à procéder aux
interdictions de 3 sur 5 puis le
gouvernement suivant cinq sur cinq
et là on revient dans certains secteurs
a en vérité souveraineté alimentaire
est-ce que c'est pas notre filière
d'huile mais en vérité en argent que
vous voyez bien qu'ils aient un dilemme
parce que en fait si on perd des
rendements sûrs si on perd tous nos
rendements sur la betterave
il ya les usines derrière kiki et puis
il fallait apporter du du sucre polonais
qui a été nourri aussi aux jeux vous
dire nous plantons des amandiers dans le
sud de la france mais restons sur les
betteraves
c'est un exemple intéressant au dessus
de la france nous plantons des amandiers
qui vont grandir et qui prendront leurs
fruits dans 5 entre trois et cinq ans
nous avons financé un programme contre
ravageur avec l'inra qui met deux trois
ans à trouver des systèmes de
biocontrôle tailleurs des systèmes
d'élimination naturel par des prêts vers
des rhumes et l'inra a travaillé aussi
pour les betteraves ils n'ont pas trouvé
en deux il ya ils n'ont pas trois pattes
ils n'ont pas trouvé mais il faut en
trouver un oui me trouvais alors là ça
donnerait supplémentaires agriculteurs
vous les connaissez bien vous les aimez
vous leur dites quoi non seulement les
habitants
l'argument que les agriculteurs ont en
leur faveur c'est que la betterave n'est
pas une plantes mellifères
c'est à dire que la bei ne va pas le but
inné mais à la limite
la cohabitation peut être tout à fait
possible temporairement si elle est
délimitée dans le temps des limitée dans
le temps et surtout si vous avez autour
de ces chants des protections pour tous
les autres c'est un lien et peter donc
et ça excusez moi pendant ce temps là il
faut que la recherche se bougent bête
une pile et et j'ai envie de dire ce
n'est une pile c'est franchement les
équipes de recherche finissent toujours
par par trou est ce que vous créez une
question de moyens ailleurs une poupée
moi je ne suis pas favorable je ne suis
pas favorable
la réintroduction de nicotine est parce
qu on aurait pu peut-être réintroduire
d'autres insecticides
ancien ou alors qu'était qui était - du
moins dévastateur et il fallait quand
même faire un petit travail plutôt que
reprendre ses études au même part de
responsabilité parce que c'était en 2016
vous étiez au gouvernement fin c'était
une scène n'était plus au gouvernement
j'ai quitté en 2004
météo france a levé ray avec monsieur
hollande mais moi je vais retenir l'état
aussi aurait pu mettre accélérer la
recherche et trouver des substituts nan
mais je suis de votre avis bien sûr mais
moi je ne vais y a mais les critiques ne
sont pas adressés à quiconque elle
compte tout le monde bien sûr il ya un
dilemme vous préféré sauver les abeilles
on le comprend vous ai fait du miel mais
on sacrifie la halle la sucrine sont
faits pour être trouvé il ya betteraves
mais c'est ça le dilemme non c'est passé
à une france le rêve tout en arrière
sonigo thing est désastreux en revanche
on aurait pu trouver d'autres méthodes
comme ça existait il ya 30 ans 1
il y avait des betteraves qui on
plantait les betteraves et ça marchait
il ya trente ans il y avait pas
néonicotinoïdes à l'époque donc ça ça
aurait mérité aussi ça m'a volé signal
qu'on envoie c'est surtout c'est surtout
un problème parce que la cohabitation
avec l'apiculture n'est pas tenable
c'est pas tenable et alors vous vos
riches là ll faut 45 apiculteur dans
toute la france oui ce que vous savez
que la bei se nourrit de la plante est
en fait son miel et donc la bei fait
parler la plante et le terroir donc le
tilleul de bourgogne c'est pas labruyère
des landes ce n'est pas la lavande de
provence ce n'est pas la bourdaine du
massif central donc nous avons des
terroirs qui s'expriment différemment
sens bien c'est ça dépend parce que le
bio en france est très difficile à
produire on en a peu certains sont bio
parce qu'on arrive à les produire
d'autres pas mais ce sont des miels de
crue c'est à dire qu'en fait ils sont
mono pollinique pour certains d'entre
eux c'est à dire qu'on ce sont des miels
qui ont qui font parler la plante et
consent le miel de ronces vous m'en
donnerez des nouvelles
autre business un peu calqué sur celui
ci c'est celui des glaces on a beaucoup
parlé cet été lors c'est plus la saison
c'est la mémère glace cette fois-ci 100%
bio comment fonctionne ce business c'est
un peu pareil j'ai vu vous achetez le
aux producteurs de lait boudin non mais
ça fonctionne vraiment là on s'associe
avec un éleveur un éleveur seulement un
héros or nous nous installons un
container avec le matériel nous le
formons donc avec un meilleur ouvrier de
france qui est artisan glacier qui
transmet son savoir faire
il apprend à transformer sa glace
semblait en glace et lui va en vente
directe nous nous vendons partout où
nous le pouvons et nous assurons quelque
sorte cette coopération entre un
producteur qui est fermier des
agriculteurs et qui devient producteur
de glace qui transforme son propre lait
est nous qui assurons le commerce et
l'investissement
donc nous protégeons l'agriculteur
contre l'endettement puisqu'en fait son
exploitation et pour réserver
nous nous associons lui à 51% nous 49 et
nous assurons à partage de la valeur en
fait on gagne de l'argent ensemble et et
nous rémunérons le leur dit c'est le
mauvais à la mauvaise rémunération des
agriculteurs
c'est le seul sujet le sujet c'est celui
là et comme on crée de la valeur dans la
ferme c'est dans la ferme que se loge la
rémunération donc ça créé deux emplois
par atelier par laboratoire le lait
rémunéré 37 % plus cher que le prix de
marché et nous partageons les bénéfices
que nous font les consommateurs ils
émettent après à il est prêt à mettre
plus cher aussi pour acheter sa glace
parce que j'imagine que tu me l'avais
c'est une gueule il n'y a pas de glaces
bio sur le marché il ya que 1,5 pour
cent du marché qui est bio le
consommateur n'a pas de très peu de
glace young et s'éteint une glace qui
fait parler à la fois les fruits mais
aussi le lait donc c'est un goût c'est
un groupe neuf et non consommateurs à
fait particulière mais il faut qu'il
mette plus cher aux pas tant que ça
enfin tant que ça franchement il ya on a
enlevé tous les produits chimiques tous
les tous les additifs alimentaires vers
donnons donc sur le plan de la santé
et d'ailleurs nous avons la meilleure
note hugh qu'à la même heure est ce que
vous entendez beaucoup parce que moi
j'ai cru comprendre que ça prenait pas
vraiment cette histoire de glace qui
avait pas beaucoup de producteurs
ah bah non mais attendez pour un produit
quand même était dans l' été dans le
bain business se sont retirés du
business c'est la rvm ça non mais
attendez
est ce qu'il ya des producteurs a tort
qui ont adhéré qui sont repartis à bord
mirman nous avons des candidatures très
nombreuses pour l'instant nous démarrons
ont fait une saison nous avons vendu 35
mille peau en quatre mois donc voilà
alors après il faut gérer l'agriculteur
est ce qu'il est d'accord pas d'accord
que ça lui plaît ça lui plaît pas
pourquoi parce que c'est un nouveau
métier pour lui d'abord c'est un micro
ateliers donc c'est du travail posté
moratoire c'est un travail posté
l'agriculteur il travaille avec les
saisons avec la nature selon la
météorologie il n'y a pas d'horaire en
revanche là c'est un travail posté et
c'est un travail qui et d'artisanat et
très très précis avec un process de
fabrication
donc il faut qu'ils apprécient ce métier
et ça c'est difficile parce que et donc
nous notre sujet c'est comment on arrive
à trouver un accord avec des
agriculteurs et un accord durable
donc nous nous sommes en train de
l'augmenter le nombre de fermes et
surtout on est en train d'augmenter le
nombre de référencement dans la grande
distribution puisque la mémère est
maintenant presque dans toutes les
enseignes
nous avons déjà 250 points de vente pour
ceux qui chercheraient le miel blanrue à
la bouche et oui bleu-blanc-rouge point
c'est ben voilà à présent et défaire
c'est le péché mignon
vous êtes le premier à nous faire le
coup arnaud montebourg on vous propose
un dessert et vous nous ramenez du
fromage donc fromage ou dessert c'est
plutôt fromages chez le rat c'est vrai
chez arnaud pour moi le fromage c'est
comme un des sphères porte un nom
étrange le cac biteau c'est mon chèvre
préféré c'est du lait de chèvre venant
de la région charolaise et il a un
caractère extraordinaire
alors il a il a un avantage pour moi il
est de saône et loire
voilà donc j'ai appris à le connaître à
l'aimer à le fréquenter
c'est c'est un fromage qui parle
voilà qui dit qui dit les schleck btu ça
veut dire quoi c'est ça c'est du patois
c'est ça veut dire prendre acte
cherchent simplement donc c'est le clac
btu on en trouve moi j'ai été je n'avais
jamais entendu je faisais trop ça se
trouve de plus en plus oui alors là où
c'est le resteront un grand hommage
comme ça c'est une sorte de cylindre
assez haut et là on vous l'a on vous l'a
servi avec un peu de sucre pour que
c'est un peu l'aspect dessert aussi
c'est certain j'aurais du miel à
déguster le miel avec le fromage qui
passe c'est qu'un seul fromage de chèvre
est parfois un petit peu plus friable
là nous entrons dans les fromageries et
les crémeries avec nos miel bio gauche
parce que nous avons réhabilité le miel
en motte qu'on coupe qui est naturel
qu'il ya un coup de main de l'apiculteur
dans sa fabrication et on le coupe au
couteau donc au poids ça le miel à la
coupe c'est magnifique alors vous avez
l'odeur qui vous prend du mieux à cette
extraordinaire et avec les fromages
alors là vous avez encore du miel
lindner vous avez vu ce masque non je
vois pas regardé avec plein de petites
abeilles
voilà c'est celui que portait cédric
villani hier à l'assemblée pour pour
contrer la loi sur les les pesticides ça
vous fait plaisir solidarité bon de
linéarité
merci mal et on termine avec cette odeur
de miel merci à vous et merci d'avoir
participé à politika thème merci aussi à
chez françoise qui nous a fourni ce très
bon vol au vent et puis rendez vous la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau
politique à table merci
[Musique]